ايران لا تزالوا تلوح بالتهديد والوعيد
لقمع الناشطين بحجه تورطهم باعمال شغب
خلال الاحتجاجات فيما يقولوا وزير
مخابراتها اسماعيل خطيب للنشاطئ في الخارج
ان ايران ستلاحقكم وتنزل بكم العقاب
سنعاقب كل من اضر بالبلاد اينما كان في
العالم وكل شخص متورط في اعمال الشغب
سيعاقب ايضا
مع ذكر الثالثه لاعتقال الناشط والصحفي
الايراني روح الله زم وايضا بعد تهديدات
الحرس الثوري ضد صحفي ايران انترناشونال
التي اعلنت في الشهر الماضي عن تهديدات
موثوقه تلقاها صحفيوها من الحرس الثوري
لكن ما هي الوسائل التي تمكن الاستخبارات
الايرانيه من الوصول الى خصومها في الخارج
لدى ايران شبكاته تجسس واذرعون في دول
مجاوره بينها تركيا والعراق
في فرنسا عام 2019 ايضا اختطف النظام
الايراني خلال السنوات الاخيره نشطاء
بينهما جمشيد شارما هاد وفرج الله كعب
المعروف بحبيب اسيا ود وايضا اختطاف مدير
مجموعه تندر الناشط شارما هاد ذو 66 عاما
من قبل عملاء ايرانيين خلال رحلته من
المانيا الى الهند في 2020
في المقابل اخفقت بعده عمليات الاختطاف
بينها خليه اسطنبول حين اعلنت تركيا عن
اعتقال اشخاص مرتبطين بعمليه اختطاف
الناشط حبيب السياده فيما القى جهاز
المخابرات التركيه القبض على 11 شخصا من
اعضاء شبكه تهريب المخدرات تابعه لناجي
شريف في زان دشتي متورطين ايضا في اختطاف
اسيا بالاضافه الى الاشتباه في قيام اعضاء
الشبكه بعمليات تجسس لصالح الحرس الثوري
ومع السيناري ملاحقه معارضيه الخارج طبقا
معضله الاساسيه
لسل الايرانيه هي احتجاجات الداخل التي لم
تخمد في شهر الثالث